cette salle du prado plume d'acier
commence à bien la connaître elle est
aux branches basket depuis 2016 année de
son entrée au centre de formation quand
on m'a appelé pour me dire que j'étais
prise au centre de formation mais je ne
connais pas je pensais même pas venir
far east est à bourges de base donc
c'était une petite surprise et ensuite
ben ouais à tous un peu enchaîné très
vite et c'est vrai que j'essaie de vivre
au jour le jour pour en profiter au
maximum
avec son mètre soixante dix huit et son
numéro 18 dans le dos elle joue au poste
de meneuse
amené à créer pour les autres ouais
j'suis pas 16 plus en braille et que
dans tir on va dire ouais j'y viens j'ai
un jeu très généreux où j'aime beaucoup
passer la balle et faire pour les
tatouages officiellement professionnel
depuis cette saison pauline astier est à
20 ans la plus jeune de l'équipe et sa
présence ne passe pas inaperçu donc ça
bien d'avoir des jeunes choisis dans son
équipe parce que ma premièrement en
valeur leur transmettre aussi un petit
peu notre expérience et puis ça amène un
petit peu de voilà un peu de jeunesse un
peu de vivacité et un peu de bonne
humeur dans la zone euro un peu de folie
aussi beaucoup de folie puis un style de
basket un peu différent aussi et donc
c'est toujours intéressant de voir ce
que le basket évolué et donc d'avoir des
jeunes joueuses comme ça dans son
effectif c'est important
plus affirmé son entraîneur l'a vu
évoluer au fil des années ces qualités
sont indéniables vitesse percussion elle
apprend vite et sa progression va
continuer là on atteindra voilà quel
niveau médian voir voir voir moyens
qu'ils soient ses os et donc c'est la
répétition de ces matches-là de ses
performances là qu'il faudra que
justement elle répondre présent à chaque
fois et c'est pas le plus simple quand
on avance mais je pense qu'elle en a
toutes les qualités et je suis sûr
qu'elle va lequel va continuer à le
montrer
avant d'arriver dans le cher pauline
astier a découvert le basket dans les
pyrénées originaire de tarbes elle est
passée par la loubère comme une certaine
céline dumerc
c'est une chose qui fédère qui donne
envie de se donner pour l'équipe pour
elle pour tous a donc ouais ce côté là
c'est quelque chose que je trouve fort
chez elle avec des parents ancien joueur
de basket pauline est bien entouré elle
espère participer aux championnats
d'europe des u20 cet été est dans un
coin de sa tête elle rêve à l'équipe de
france à mais pas question de brûler les
étapes
j'aime bien prendre le temps de faire
les choses correctement comprend
pourquoi je les fais donc c'est vrai
qu'avec toutes les choses que j'ai
autour de moi ça me permet de faire ça
et pas plus mal je sais pas mettre
pression est trop d'objectifs non plus
parce que je sais que ça va me prendre
la tête après mais je suis arrivé à ses
grilles verra